people expect computers to be entirely
accurate and precise with numbers you
know you grow it with calculators you
expect that if you type in naught point
one plus not point - you expect it to
come out
- not point three and sooner or later
every programmer as they're learning try
something like that and they type it
into a programming language something
like nought point one plus nine point
two and they will hit Enter
and what the computer will give them is
something like Northpoint 301 and at
that point people have started to learn
about floating-point numbers and they
will be starting to tear the hair out
floating-point numbers are essentially
scientific notation um so let's just for
the uninitiated let's say you an
astrophysicist and you have you know the
speed of light which is this enormous
number with eight zeros after it and you
want to multiply it by a tiny distance
doesn't really matter what we're
measuring here this just your big number
small number let's say naught point
naught naught naught naught 1 5 let's
say you want to multiply these two
together may have made this a bit
deliberately easy you could try and do
some really complicated maths and worked
all out but you don't need to because in
scientific notation this is 3 times 10
to the 8th and this one is 1.5 times 10
to the minus 7 so you don't need to do
anything particularly complicated to
multiply these two together all you have
to do is multiply these which is 4.5 and
then add these exponents together here
so 8 add - 7 8 - 7 means that's 1 so
we're looking for 4.5 times 10 to the 1
or 4 point 5 times 10 or 45 brilliant
that's much easier than trying to
actually handle large numbers and it
also brings us to the concept of
significant figures because the speed of
light isn't exactly 3 times 10 to the
8th it's 2.99
7 something and there's a lot of digits
on the end of there which don't really
matter for everyday calculations we
round it up we say it's 3 times 10 to
the 8th or maybe if we're being precise
we say which seats to point
nine nine seven times ten to the eighth
but we don't really worry about the
numbers beyond that hold that thought
so we'll come back to significant digits
later the two main advantages to
floating-point are speed and efficiency
and speed because floating-point has
been built over many many years it is
now lightning fast for computers to deal
with and efficiency because it can deal
with really big numbers massive numbers
size of the universe numbers and really
small numbers you have size of an atom
numbers without needing enormous amounts
of space if you had a format that needed
to include the size of the universe and
the size of an atom you'd need so many
zeros is stored on both ends or you'd
need something particularly complicated
for a computer to work out that it would
be either really inefficient storing one
number as a megabyte or you would need
something that would be really fiddly
for a computer to work out it tries to
place all the zeros and the numbers
everywhere let's talk about base ten
let's talk about us people let's talk
about Lights being on all the sudden
that's weird um in base ten in our
normal human numbers sodium ten digits
base ten we have hundreds tens and units
you learn that in primary school and
over here you have tenths hundredths and
thousandths so if you want to say one
tenth in decimal you say zero point one
and that's normal and that's natural
base two on the other hand binary
computers they don't do that because
what they see of fours twos and ones and
then over here halves quarters eighths
and sixteenths there's no naught point
one in there in fact not point one in
binary is naught point naught naught
naught 1 1 and that naught naught 1 1 is
recurring it's actually not point naught
naught naught 1 1 naught naught 1 1
naught naught 1 1 naught naught 1 1 all
the way to infinity which is interesting
because 32-bit computers you know the
ones we generally use we moved a bit on
now first two bit computers only store
23 significant
they also store where the decimal point
is and they basically do scientific
notation in base two that's what
floating point is and so they say all
right so we've got this long binary
number times two to the something and
that's a problem because what it loses
is precision it doesn't understand the
recursion and there's an analogy for
that in base ten if you try and write a
third as a decimal we go hundreds tens
units tenths hundredths thousandths and
then we try and do this and we end up
with naught point three three three
three three three three three recurring
now imagine you don't understand
recurring numbers like your computer
like scientific notation has to be take
away that recursion like floating-point
arithmetic doesn't so this is where we
bring everything together if you're in
base ten if you're in decimal let's say
you have one-third plus one-third plus
one-third as humans we go well that's
not point three recurring that's not
point three recurring that's not point
three recurring which is one but say
you're a computer and you don't
understand recursion because floating
point math is essentially significant
figures so computer would look at that
and go north point three three three
three three three plus three three three
pursue and it will say well 1/3 plus 1/3
plus 1/3 total it to naught point nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine then after
a while you'll stop because you've run
out of digits what you've just got there
is a floating-point rounding error let's
take another base tube let's do one
tenth plus two texts which is no point
north naught naught 1 1 naught naught 1
1 naught naught 1 1 naught naught 1 1 oh
we've run out of digits because
floating-point arithmetic on 32-bit
computers only stores 23 digits and then
you try and add to tax which is naught
point naught naught 1 1 naught naught 1
1 naught naught 1 I'm not going to try
and do that maths because it's going to
take ages but what happens is exactly
this
as back here after 23 digits in 32-bit
arithmetic regatta you've got 56 on
64-bit computers it cuts it doesn't
understand recurring which means that
floating-point looks at 1/10 plus 2/10
what you just typed in naught point 1
plus not point 2 in decimal and it says
that 1/10 plus 2/10 does not quite equal
3/10 because to its mind it doesn't for
nearly all cases it is close enough in
most cases you don't need more than 23
binary digits of precision if you do you
go to 64 bit if you are doing a 3d game
and you need to know where to point
something on the screen it doesn't
matter if it's a hundred thousandth of a
pixel out because it'll be in the right
place and if you're doing big
calculations it doesn't matter if a tiny
tiny tiny fraction something smaller
than a molecule is out because it'll
look more or less right right beyond any
precision or tolerance that the real
world could possibly manage but it means
that if you're dealing with currency and
you say that you are adding 10 pence or
naught point one pounds to 20 pence
every programmer hits this sooner or
later we just go like that that's easy a
computer will come back and say well
that's that's actually that many pence
and then these particular human things
we will notice the error because
suddenly to us it's very very obvious
that's the problem with floating-point
to fix that by the way if you do in
currency you either use a decimal type
in more advanced programming languages
or you just store everything as the
integer in terms of pence or cents or
whatever and then divide by 100 at the
end floating-point is something that
really really confuses a lot of people
it's tough to get your head around until
you realize that it is just scientific
notation it's the same thing that we
learned in maths class at school only in
base2 it's kill halves and quarters and
eighths and once you once you crack that
once you realize that it's storing a set
length of number and then working out
where the decimal point could be and
it's just significant figures it starts
to become a lot easier and you start to
realize oh that's why if I type point
one plus point two what I get
isn't point three
whether it's in light or in shade so how
do we determine the shading of the pixel
is local and we don't have information
about the rest of the scenes so we can't
know and now you have two populations of
people in the same location who are
following different time zones